ce monde france en métropole comme en
outre-mer je vois à quel point à force
de renoncements et d'immobilisme
françois hollande et emmanuel macron ou
abîmés notre pays il est devenu urgent
de réparer la france
je suis candidate à la présidence de la
république pour restaurer notre pays
malgré l'ampleur du chantier qui est
devant nous je ne me résous jamais au
déclin je suis une optimiste et surtout
je suis une volontariste j'ai les
remèdes avec un projet de société
travaille et audacieux radical un projet
de franche rupture et de droite assumé
pour défendre notre civilisation face à
ceux qui veulent la détruire remettre de
l'ordre dans la rue et dans les comptes
redonner de la dignité de la liberté et
de la fierté à chaque français
j'ai aussi le caractère non je n'aurais
pas la main qui tremble à partir du mois
de décembre
les vraies difficultés commencent il va
falloir battre culture
c'est un président caméléon et des
extrêmes particulièrement vigoureux j'ai
une volonté de faire une énergie air
fatigué
je ne l'achète
[Musique]
lui avec ses promesses
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
shirani et oui chez nous déjà il ya une
présidente
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le secrétaire général shair
aurélien
mes chers compagnons chers amis alors
j'ai j'ai quelques supporteurs si
quelques supporters ch'tis oui ça existe
à l'heure du déjeuner ils m'ont dit pour
réveiller la salle après ce déjeuner il
va falloir ça que dans
je ne sais pas bien ce que ça veut dire
mais j'ai compris l'esprit falloir zack
and un bon
donc je vais sacs à main les amis 1
[Applaudissements]
nous voilà réunis et j'en suis
profondément heureuse au mois de
septembre vous m'avez tendu la main vous
m'avez tendu la main vous avez accepté
que je puisse être votre candidate à la
présidence de la république et cette
main tendue cette confiance elle
m'honore et l m'engage c'est pour cela
que je suis revenu dans la famille et
que j'ai accepté dès le début toutes les
règles du jeu que vous avez fixé parce
que un chef avant de rassembler son pays
il doit d'abord rassemblé ses amis
[Applaudissements]
oui jeunes gaullistes j'ai appris aux
côtés de jacques chirac à chasser en
meute alors tu étais déjà la chaire
christian aux avant-postes et je veux te
remercier des efforts constants que tu a
déployé avec notre président d'honneur
gérard larcher bien évidemment pour
réunir la famille et aujourd'hui je le
dis la famille elle est là elle est
forte et elle est réunie
[Applaudissements]
je vais aussi avoir un petit mot à jean
leonetti parce que jean leonetti il a
cru dès le début qu'on pourrait
sélectionner nos candidats à travers des
débats utiles serein et constructif et
ben oui il avait raison merci à tous
merci à michel merci à xavier merci à
philippe merci eric merci à tous les
parlementaires merci aux présidents de
fédérations aux secrétaires
départementaux à vous les cadres merci
aussi à tous les responsables jeunes du
mouvement vous n'avez pas céder à la
facilité de la division mais bien au
contraire vous avez donner toutes ses
chances à la démocratie démocratie
militante et c'est comme ça que le 4
décembre nous allons pouvoir nous réunir
alors oui je vous le dis
nous avons déjoué tous les pronostics
pessimistes et malveillant et je vous
l'affirmer avec certitude
le 4 décembre
nous serons tous rassemblés tous
mobilisés derrière celui ou celle
je vous avoue j'ai une petite préférence
que vous aurez désignés pour aller
battre emmanuel macron
car oui je le sais je le sent la
victoire elle est à notre portée et tout
est possible tout est possible grâce à
vous et grâce à notre résistance parce
que contrairement à d'autres nous
n'avons pas à brader nos convictions à
la foire aux trahisons
au parlement avec bruno anniversaire
avec damien avec françois-xavier nous
n'avons rien lâché dans nos communes
dans nos départements dans nos régions
nous avons renforcé nos positions
alors oui aux élections régionales
emmanuel macron a lancé contre moi et
mon équipe cinq de ses ministres si vous
dire qu'il me redoute et dans une région
qu'il croyait acquises dans la région
soit disant en marche de l'île de france
je leur ai fait regretter le voyage
alors oui à mes amis à six mois de la
présidentielle sachez le dit le croyez
le la droite est de retour
ne croyez pas les sondages vous les
connaissez ils se sont toujours trompés
ne croyez pas les sondages les sondages
ça va et vient c'est comme la queue du
chien
oui notre victoire nous allons l'arraché
nous allons l'arraché mais une victoire
c'est d'abord une affaire dans vie est
ce que je suis venu vous dire ici
aujourd'hui c'est que cette envie je lai
et je viens ici pour gagner
alors notre pays saura 10 mai de deux
quinquennats
un quinquennat pour rien un quinquennat
pour presque rien
montée de la violence hollande macron
mais l'échec dettes et déficits records
historiques
immigration pire qu'avant et le nouveau
monde le nouveau monde absentéisme
massif absence après dont abstention
massive gilet jaune walk isma tous les
étages extrême droite au zénith la
déconstruction est en marche voilà où
nous amener la présidence caméléon du en
même temps et du mois d'abord
jupiter a étouffé tous les corps
intermédiaires
à force de vouloir être partout le
pouvoir s'est révélé à la fois as
fiction pour les français mais aussi un
puissant pour résoudre les priorités
nationales
il faut que ça s'arrête la france a
besoin de nous
nous nous un quart dont l'ordre la
liberté et la justice
nous sommes les héritiers d'une histoire
qui ne vibre pas aux paroles capitularde
de pétain mais au souvenir des marins
rebelles de l'île de sant de gaulle
malraux pompidou chirac sarkozy et tant
d'autres encore comme vous je ne les
oublie pas je ne renie rien et je
prolonge le combat c'est un combat pour
la république française que ni
l'indécision du pouvoir actuel ni la
démagogie des extrêmes ne sont capables
de redresser d'une main ferme et juste
c'est un combat pour la souveraineté
une souveraineté crédible et active pas
une souveraineté à crédit l'échec de
macron c'est de la dette
avec macron l'addition c'est après les
élections
alors un combat pas non plus pour une
souveraineté naïve sans réciprocité
commerciale et politique pas plus qu une
souveraineté retrancher derrière une
nouvelle ligne maginot
je veux une france 2 vous en tête de
l'europe une france qu'on respecte dans
le monde pas une france qui chute en
seconde division
il ne tient qu'à nous de reprendre en
main notre destin nous nous sommes
condamnés ni aux grandes et classement
ni au grand remplacement ni à la
chienlit ni à la faillite alors oui je
veux remettre de l'ordre dans la rue et
de notre économie
[Applaudissements]
si je porte un projet de franche rupture
c'est qu'il ya plus de temps à perdre il
faut tout dire avant l'élection plutôt
que d'hésiter après et puis j'ai la
conviction que les français ne veulent
plus de demi mesure alors on me dit
parfois que j'y vais trop fort
et ben oui je cherche à faire et pas à
plaire et puis si nous n'agissons pas
maintenant et puis seulement quand le
ferons nous quand le ferons nous lorsque
la chine fera de nous un comptoir pour
ses routes de la soie lorsque les
policiers jetteront leurs menottes aux
pieds des voyous lorsque les français
seront des étrangers dans leur propre
pays c'est là qu'on réagir à l'urgence
elle est sous nos yeux elle est
identitaire elle est sécuritaire elle
est économique écologique européenne
aussi car l'europe doit se ressaisir
mais l'europe ne se ressaisira que si la
france est forte et nous ne serons forts
à l'extérieur que si nous sommes aussi
forts à l'intérieur parce qu on ne
pilote pas l'europe
on ne pilote pas l'europe ont
n'impressionne pas pékin washington
moscou où ankara lorsqu'on est faible
chez soi lorsqu'on est criblé de dettes
lorsqu'on est bousculé par les black
block ou encore lorsqu'on fait pénitence
en reconnaissant des crimes contre
l'humanité que nous n'avons jamais
commis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut réagir ferme il faut réagir vite
et j'y suis prête j'ai l'autorité et
l'expérience
avec le soutien de nicolas sarkozy de
françois fillon j'ai tenu neuf mois face
à la rue pour réussir l'autonomie des
universités en 2011
en 2011 et en 2012 j'ai géré les
finances de notre pays en pleine tempête
financière
j'ai conquis et je dirige une grande
région une région qui est riche mais qui
est aussi terriblement inégalitaire une
région qui est urbaine mais qui aussi
rural n'est ce pas christian rural je
connais les colères et les injustices
d'une société bloquée dans lesquelles
les classes populaires ont perdu le rêve
de s'élever plus haut et dans laquelle
les classes moyennes ont terriblement
peur de chuter plus bas alors ascenseur
social en panne pouvoir d'achat en berne
on ne réglera pas les problèmes à coups
tchèque on ne règle on les réglera par
une nouvelle croissance une croissance
verte pas par la décroissance on le
réglera par une vraie politique de
l'emploi avec une vraie revalorisation
du travail par un sursaut éducatif
national
et puis par une baisse des charges et
des impôts qui ne sera possible que si
l'état et mieux gérer ce qui n'a pas été
fait depuis cinq ans alors je rappelle
au président macron qui a cramé la
caisse mais aussi à madame le pen qui
veut revenir à la retraite à 60 ans que
pour gagner collectivement plus il faut
produire plus travailler plus et
dépenser mois tout autre discours est
mensonger et antisociales parce qu on ne
sauvera pas notre modèle social avec des
assignats
à la tête de l'île de france
je suis debout et en première ligne face
aux adversaires de la république ceux
qui tiennent les checkpoints pour
protéger leur trafic et leur rodéo ceux
qui répandent sur notre sol un nouvel
antisémitisme
ceux qui veulent imposer leurs lois
leurs fois au dessus de notre loi
alors islamo gauchiste et autres
indigéniste ont saisi la justice contre
moi mais je ne cède pas je refuse toute
subvention aux associations qui ne
respectent pas la république et la
laïcité
j'ai interdit le port du burkini dans le
style de loisirs
la femme française je la veux libre ni
enfermée chez elle ni harcelé dans la
rue
[Applaudissements]
mes amis je voulais dit ma france ne
sera jamais soumise
je soutiens et je soutiendrai
indéfectiblement nos forces de l'ordre
je mettrai le paquet sur notre justice
afin que la peur change de camp
impunité 0 je ne fais ni dans
l'angélisme ni dans la repentance ni
dans la culture de l'excusé ni
d'ailleurs dans la lutte des races car
au delà des origines et des prénoms je
regarde ce qu'il y a dans le coeur des
femmes et des hommes et si ce choeur et
courageux s'il est honnête si les
patriotes alors il est des nôtres
n'oublions jamais la devise de la légion
étrangère français non par le sang reçu
mais par le sang versé
alors tout commence dans les familles de
france donc je veux soutenir la natalité
en revenant à l'universalité de notre
politique familiale
on la laissait détricoter c'est une
fierté française
tout se poursuit à l'école là où nos
enfants doivent apprendre à aimer leur
pays oui nous n'avons pas à rougir
d'avoir eu des héros nos enfants doivent
être guidés sur les chemins de la
culture et de la raison contre lens
sauvagement des émotions et contre tout
les complotisme la transmission de notre
langue et de nos sciences doit être la
priorité du socle des connaissances
fondamentales
le français lire écrire compter d'ici
cinq ans nous devons nous donner pour
objectif de retrouver les meilleures
places dans les classements
internationaux
parce qu'il est indigne que la patrie de
molière et d'hugo de charpak et de marie
curie soit à la traîne je me bats pour
une fierté française retrouvée parce qu
un peuple fier est invincible
oui il existe une identité française oui
il existe une culture française un art
de vivre à la française
en un mot une civilisation et tout cela
doit être défendu défendu notamment aux
frontières aux frontières car
l'immigration incontrôlée
non contrôlée non assimilés peu disloqué
une nation alors oui il y a un lien
entre immigration et terrorisme
islamiste oui il ya un lien aussi entre
immigration et délinquance
un lien c'est pas un signe égal mais si
nous voulons résoudre les problèmes hors
de question de s'aveugler plus longtemps
l'immigration actuelle doit être stoppée
quotas migratoires je vois que tout le
monde s'y est praille et j'en suis
heureuse quotas migratoires le principe
on choisit qui on accueille asile pour
les persécutés charters pour les
clandestins
ma france elle est ferme elle est ferme
parce qu'elle veut être respecté mais
elle est aussi humanistes et
universelles
humanistes et universelles ça veut dire
qu'elle est attentive au sort du
continent africain dont dépend notre
propre sort elle est fraternelle avec
les chrétiens d'orient est les amis de
la francophonie
oui
universel car la liberté tricolore elle
qui monta sur les barricades contre les
injustices cette liberté doit parler à
ceux qui dans le monde sont asservis
bayonnais ou voilée comme à kaboul pour
la france doit toujours être cette
lumière qui brille dans la nuit cet
espoir de liberté qui ne s'éteindra
jamais
mes chers amis avec vous je restaurer la
fierté française parce qu une nation
fière va de l'avant c'est une nation qui
ne tremble pas devant l'adversité avec
la france
rien n'est jamais fichu il suffit d'un
homme ou d'une femme qui se dresse et
qui dit non non au renoncement non au
déclin non au découragement mais qui dit
oui oui à l'action oui au courage oui à
l'espérance je vous la sueur rien
n'arrête un peuple qui se lève pour
retrouver sa fierté et conquérir son
bonheur
alors je le sais sur le chemin de la
victoire il y aura des obstacles il y
aura des vents contraires on nous
attaquera on our poussera mais nous
passerons nous passerons par la force de
nos idées et par notre unité sans faille
ceux qui voudront nous faire barrage ne
savent pas ce qu'est une femme qui ne
lâche rien une française libre qui à la
france au coeur alors oui je sollicite
votre confiance sacrée le jeu suit
totalement entièrement viscéralement
déterminer je suis prête à engager le
combat je suis prête à présider la
france
[Applaudissements]
merci chers amis
même si même si belle équipe alors une
première question pour lancer le débat
ja valérie danton clip tu fais un
constat très sombre la situation de la
france une france abîmée je reprends le
terme que tu as utilisé en effet une
france abîmée par 50 socialisme par cinq
ans de maquereaux nisme et qu'il nous
faut réparer alors la question serait
posée c'est comment fait-on pour à la
fois être fort puissant dans la
dénonciation la dénonciation d'un
constat qui est quand même accablant sur
à peu près tous les sujets et en même
temps donner aux français de l'espoir
parce que je crois aussi que la campagne
présidentielle c'est le moment où on
peut donner aux français avoir un
horizon meilleur donc comment faire pour
que notre famille politique incarne à la
fois et l'un et l'autre sans affaiblir
l'un et l'autre
tu as raison annie il faut qu'on incarne
cet expert cette espérance mais moi je
crois dans le génie français et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce génie français il est
en permanence entre avait il est en
permanence entravée par une bureaucratie
qui est devenu tellement envahissante
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus créer on
ne peut plus produire on ne peut plus
construire ça prend des années et des
années
tu sais j'ai regardé le programme de
gouvernement du futur chancelier
allemand monsieur olaf scholz c'est
intéressant de connaître ses futurs
partenaires de gouvernement monsieur
scholtes il est socialiste et
socialistes allemands il va faire une
alliance avec les libéraux et avec les
verts allemands qui vous l'avez compris
eux sont des écologistes et pas des
gauchistes contrairement au nôtre
monsieur monsieur kalt il a mis dans son
programme il a mis dans son programme
que en allemagne il allait diviser par
deux la durée de toutes les procédures
administratives allemande eh bien il ya
de quoi trembler parce que si les
allemands réussissent à combien
d'investisseurs
on aura sur le territoire français
combien on aura deux chercheurs sur le
territoire français combien en aura deux
créateurs sur le territoire français
toutes les usines se créeront de l'autre
côté de la frontière parce
qu'aujourd'hui faut être sacrément
patriotes l'autre jour j'étais en
bretagne j'étais en bretagne avec un un
grand industriel de l'agroalimentaire
breton qui qui a une entreprise
familiale et il me disait vous vous
rendez compte de ce que c'est que la
concurrence aujourd'hui de la grande
bretagne
juste l'autre côté du bras de mer qui
respecte plus les normes européennes et
qui est en train de faire des zones des
zones franches fiscale partout il faut
être sacrément patriotes pour créer
aujourd'hui une usine en france quand on
est soumis à autant de pression j'étais
à sens dans l'yonne avec marie louise
fort elle me disait elle me disait elle
me disait on a un très très beau projet
à sens mais ça fait neuf mois qu'on
attend le passage de l'archéologie
préventive
neuf mois ils ont tour ils ont le
terrain ils ont l'argent ça va créer de
l'emploi
neuf mois alors moi j'adore
l'archéologie préventive j'aime le
patrimoine j'aime l'histoire et j'aime
la transmission mais enfin on peut
peut-être se dire qu'au bout d'un mois
ci l'archéologie préventive n'est pas
passé eh ben ils ont passé leur tour et
peu c'est le moment de créer des emplois
c'est le moment d'investir
donc je crois profondément à la
débureaucratisation vous avez peut-être
vu david lisnard
david lisnard qui vient de qui vient
d'envoyer un sacré camouflet à emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron qui voulait que
tous les maires soient rangés et aligné
comme dirait nicolas sarkozy comme les
petits pois dans une boîte eh bien il à
david lisnard avec sa superbe victoire à
l'association des maires de france a
montré que les maires resterait
indépendant mais alors il a fait surtout
quelque chose de magnifique il a fait un
superbe discours que emmanuel macron a
été obligé d'entendre jusqu'au bout et
dans cette magnifique discours il a
expliqué
l'empilement des schémas et des plans
d'urbanisation quand on veut construire
du logement en france il est parti du
pays et lui ensuite il est arrivé sur
les scot laissera dette voilà enfin je
vais vous voulez passez vous les
connaissez tous et il a dit voilà
monsieur le président la france que vous
nous laissez et effectivement il faut
libérer l'énergie des français libérer
l'énergie des français mais ça vaut
partout on en parlait avec philippe
juvin ça vaut à l'hôpital si on donnait
plus de pouvoir aux soignants à
l'hôpital et moins à l'administration
ça vaut à l'école ça vaut à l'école si
on donnait dans les écoles beaucoup plus
d'autonomie pédagogique aux enseignants
et qu'on avait un peu moins de crouch
administrative ans pourrait revaloriser
toutes les carrières donc oui il faut
libérer les énergies de nos
entrepreneurs il faut libérer l'énergie
de nos chercheurs pourquoi n'y a pas de
vaccin français alors que le patron de
moderna et français pourquoi il n'y a
pas de google français alors que dans la
silicon valley tous les inventeurs du
numérique sont français c'est ça la
vérité on les a laissés partir on les a
laissés partir parce qu'on est une
société de la précaution excessive pas
une société de l'innovation
il faut retrouver cet esprit
d'innovation il faut retrouver cette
liberté de créer et d'entreprendre et
c'est comme ça shirani qu'on leur
donnera l'espoir
valérie valérie je voudrais te parler de
l'enfance dans notre pays un enfant
meurt sous les coups des violences tous
les 5 jours en 2018 plus de 340 mille
enfants étaient placés sous protection
et depuis deux ans nous avons une
augmentation de près de 15 % chaque
année en europe sont 25 millions
d'enfants qui vivent dans des situations
de pauvreté plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'enfants qui n'accèdent pas à
l'école de la république parce qu'ils
sont en situation de handicap notre
famille politique historiquement a
toujours fait de l'enfance un sujet
majeur pour reconstruire un pays il faut
de la natalité il faut traiter la
question démographique on le fait par
l'enfance il faut porter une espérance
pour les futurs citoyens de demain il
faut traiter l'école l'éducation
l'ascenseur social la progression la
protection l'autorité parentale et la
famille est-ce que ce sujet de l'enfance
et au delà de la jeunesse dans un grand
et beau pays comme le nôtre ne doit pas
devenir demain une priorité nationale
aussi grande que tous les sujets que
nous pouvons évoquer quotidiennement
alors c'est un sujet qui peut nous
emmener loin et qui sait c'est un sujet
qui m'est cher puisque quand j'étais
député j'ai présidé la mission sur la
famille et sur la protection de
l'enfance et à l'époque nous avions nous
avions fait une une avancée majeure qui
était le secret partagé le secret
partagé par tous les professionnels de
l'enfance dans des conseils de
protection de l'enfance de façon à ce
que quand un professeur voit que quelque
chose se passe quand un animateur voit
que quelque chose se passe va perdre
tout le monde ne reste pas dans son
couloir mais qu'au contraire tout le
monde se parle alors il y a une très
très belle création qui avait été fait
il ya quelques années mais qui avait été
généralisé rendu obligatoire par nicolas
sarkozy qui s'appelle le conseil des
droits et devoirs des familles tu t'en
souviens nadine conseil des droits et
devoirs des familles présidés par les
maires dans lesquels on invite tous les
professionnels de l'enfance et on
discute et on discute des cas à problème
et bien c'est conseil des droits et
devoirs de la famille moi je crois qu'il
faut les rendre à nouveau obligatoire et
pouvoir les généraliser dans des villes
beaucoup plus petit des villes toutes
les villes qui le souhaiteront bien sûr
mais à partir de dix mille habitants les
rendre obligatoires pour ah parce qu'on
a aussi tu n'en parle pas mais montée de
la violence des jeunes de plus en plus
jeunes on a besoin d'aider les parents
c'est difficile d'être parent
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile c'est
très difficile quand on a les réseaux
sociaux quand on ne sait pas ce que nos
enfants regardent quand on a les
addictions on a le mal être on a le
harcèlement on a aussi une santé mentale
qui est en déshérence avec très peu de
psychologues très peu de psychiatres
c'est très difficile d'avoir des
consultations pour aider un enfant qui
est qui et qui est en situation de
mal-être donc il faut tout repenser et
l'intérêt de ces conseils des droits et
devoirs des familles c'est de permettre
aussi de redresser la barre très vite
quand quelque chose ne va pas et le
signal évidemment un enfant lorsqu'il
est lorsqu'il est battu moi ma grande
cause mais deux grandes causes pour le
prochain quinquennat il y en aura deux
de grandes causes sociales puisque je
sais cher aurélien que le social ne
tient particulièrement à coeur la
première ce sera la lutte contre la
désertification médicale parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas continuer
à être un pays dans lequel est bien on a
moins de 100000 généralistes c'est ça la
réalité moins de 100000 généralistes et
dans lequel et dans lequel on ne trouve
pas à se soigner il ya des villes et des
villages entiers dans lequel les
habitants n'ont plus de médecin traitant
et puis on à l'hôpital l'hôpital dans
lequel nos soignants aujourd'hui va se
retrouvent se retrouve dépassée
déboussolés épuisé par la crise qu vide
et on a trop de démission trop de
fermetures de services donc la première
de mettre en cause du quinquennat ce
sera la lutte contre la désertification
médicale si vous avez des questions je
détaillerai mon projet sur sur ce sujet
la deuxième de mes grandes causes
nationales ce sera la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire parce que je ne me
résous pas à ce que la france devienne
un pays dit mobilité sociale
immobilité social ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
au journée d'appel à la défense il ya
125 mille jeunes qui n'arrivent pas à
lire le texte qu'on leur donne
il est reese est encore aujourd'hui une
réalité dans notre pays et personne ne
veut le voir personne ne veut le dire
personne n'en parle et par ailleurs dans
les classements internationaux je viens
de le dire nous sommes derniers en
europe sur l'apprentissage des
mathématiques ça n'est pas possible pas
nous pas la france pas le grand pays des
sciences alors on se rassure on se
rassure en se disant les 20% meilleur
reste les 20% meilleur mais mais c'est
pas ça la france c'est pas ça la droite
sociale nous notre droite c'est une
droite qui permet aux fils d'ouvrier de
devenir cadre dès lors qu'ils jouent le
jeu de la république dès lors qu'ils
travaillent dès lors qu'il apprend à
l'école alors comment est ce qu'on fait
eh bien on fait une vraie réforme de
l'éducation nationale mais c'est même
plus que ça on fait un sursaut national
pour l'école sursaut national pour
l'école ça veut dire croire ça veut dire
qu'on se mirent à face aux syndicats
l'éducation nationale et on va
déconstruire leur discours d'abord les
fondamentaux
l'objectif de l'école le premier
objectif c'est de donner à chaque enfant
de france les fondamentaux pour réussir
dans la vie réussir sa vie lire écrire
compter
alors oui je veux deux heures de plus de
français deux heures de plus de français
et une heure de plus de mathématiques
par semaine dans le primaire on fera des
dictées on fera des poésies on fera des
concours d'éloquence on fera tout ce
qu'on veut mais on ne peut pas réussir
dans la vie si on parle pas sa langue et
puis à la fin en cm2 on fera un examen
d'entrée en sixième non pas pour que les
élèves échouent moi je ne veux pas
mettre les jeunes dans une spirale de
sélection par l'échec tous ceux qui le
le réussir je veux que tout le monde le
réussissent mais ceux qui le réussiront
pas ils rentreront au collège parce
qu'on va pas laisser des grands
gaillards de 12 ans avec les tout petits
ils rentreront collège dans des sixièmes
de consolidation parce que le collège
unique
l'uniforme le mythe de l'uniformité a
créé les inégalités et qu'il faut qu'en
sixième c'est ses enfants apprennent à
nouveau du français et des matons va pas
leur faire de la physique on va pas leur
faire de l'anglais alors qu'il maîtrise
pas les fondamentaux et donc on les
réparera et on fera du décrochage
scolaire notre grande cause nationale je
veux créer une réserve éducative
nationale comme il ya une réserve de la
gendarmerie nationale j'appellerai les
professeurs retraités j'appellerai les
étudiants j'appellerai tous les
retraités qui le souhaitent d'ailleurs
et qui ont de l'énergie en cumul emploi
retraite gelé rémunéré pour faire du
soutien scolaire gratuit pour les
enfants des familles dès le primaire
nous devons faire réussir chaque enfant
de france c'est pas vrai que l'école de
la république est gratuite lll coûte le
prix des petits cours particuliers qu'on
donne à ses enfants alors il faut
remédier à tout ça
par ailleurs
j'en ai assez du dénigrement de
l'enseignement professionnel
systématique alors moi je le dis
l'enseignement professionnel les lycées
professionnels ont les confiera aux
régions et on confiera aussi aux régions
l'orientation des jeunes avec avec le
monde de l'entreprise et sur un
territoire parce que les opportunités
d'emploi elles sont différentes d'un
territoire à l'autre et c'est les
entreprises qui viendront expliquer aux
jeunes que
l'enseignement professionnel
l'apprentissage ce sont des voies
d'avenir ce sont des voix on peut faire
carrière et ils parleront des sujets
tabous ils parleront des salaires ils
parleront des perspectives et c'est
comme ça qu'on changera les choses alors
on défie cieux j'enlèverai toutes les
charges patronales pour les
entrepreneurs de d'entreprises de moins
de 10 salariés qui prendront des
apprentis parce que l'apprentissage
c'est une voie de réussite chaque jeune
un talent le problème c'est le faire
éclore et tous les jeunes n'ont pas
forcément le talent d'aller passer un
bac général donc c'est pas ces on n'est
pas condamné à vie on n'est pas dans une
case à vie parce qu'on n'a pas eu un bac
1 bac à 17 ans je veux une société qui
aussi à l'école travaille sur le mérite
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que je
rétablirai les bourgs sommet et pour les
bacheliers mention très bien que najat
vallaud belkacem a supprimé je les ai
déjà rétabli dans ma région il faut les
rétablir au niveau national
pourquoi parce que ces jeunes ils
doivent être ils doivent être ils
doivent être un exemple pour leur
quartier ils sont un exemple pour leurs
familles doivent être un exemple pour
leur quartier un exemple pour leur lycée
et ils doivent être la fierté de la
république
donc nous devons les saluer et puis
évidemment je lutterai contre
l'autocensure parce que dans un
département rural comme le tien cher
aurélien 50 % seulement des bacheliers
poursuivront leurs études alors que dans
une ville universitaire c'est 80 %
pourquoi c'est tout simple c'est quand
on habite dans une ville universitaire
on vit chez papa maman et que le coût de
la vie dans une ville universitaire est
en général très élevé donc qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour que les
départements pour que les jeunes des
départements ruraux ne soient pas
victimes d'autocensure eh bien il faudra
faire ce que j'ai initiées en
ile-de-france à montereau en dans le sud
cinéma on fera des campus connecter des
campus connecté pour pouvoir faire sa
première année d'université dans son
lycée et je créerai une banque nationale
des jeunes qui financera les études des
jeunes qui les financera il ne
rembourseront ces emprunts que s'ils
gagnent un certain montant de salaire
c'est comme ça que dans la plupart des
pays on permet de lutter contre
l'autocensure je veux que chaque jeune
de france et sa chance merci merci
valérie on passe aux questions donc le
micro bleus s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont rapidement dans annie je
m'aperçois que je n'ai pas répondu sur
la question du handicap je veux en dire
un tout petit mot parce que je vois que
emmanuel macron est en train de fermer
toute une série de structures d'accueil
spécialisée pour les enfants handicapés
les femmes ont un handicap c'est la voix
donc pour les enfants handicapés je vois
emmanuel macron fermé de plus en plus de
structures et moi je prends l'engagement
auprès de toi il n'y aura plus des
milliers de français obligés d'aller
l'autre côté de la frontière en belgique
pour trouver les structures médicalisées
dont ils ont besoin pour les accueillir
c'est une indignité française et nous y
mettrons fin
vous avez la parole
et creysse bonjour chers amis il avait
l'air bien déléguer la 5e
circonscription des côtes d'armor en
bretagne
je suis un paysan et c'est avant tout à
ce titre que j'interviens
j'ai la tristesse de vous annoncer que
si deux continueront à poursuivre le
chemin emprunté actuellement édictées
par les extrémistes les lobbys extremis
la france
vivra des pénuries alimentaires avant 20
ans
avant 20 ans alors beaucoup d'entre nous
il est convenu d'entre nous je pense aux
élus de notre famille politique y
compris tous les élus
ont un langage convenu de dire que la
solution c'est dans le biologique vous
savez moi je suis producteur de légumes
j'ai pas attendu qu'on me dise de faire
du biologique pour faire la moitié de ma
de production de fer du sans pesticides
mais je voudrais donner une petite image
à l'assemblée ici aujourd'hui présent le
biologique pour tous demain n'est pas
possible
la petite image que je veux vous donner
c'est celle de enlever les mauvaises
herbes dans des carottes dans une
parcelle de carottes sachez que
l'agriculture biologique se fait sourire
certains utilisent des fourchettes celle
que vous allez utiliser ce soir pour
d'idées pour cercle et les parcelles de
carottes imaginez toute la france
comment dire obligé de faire
l'agriculture biologique utilisé ces
pratiques nous sommes plus au vin au 19e
siècle où plus de la moitié pop de la
population est agriculteur donc
qu'envisagez vous mais je vous pose à
vous cette question mais aussi aux
autres candidats pour donner un peu
d'espoir à l'agriculture et fait en
sorte que l'agriculture de demain
devienne une agriculture de premier rang
vous savez j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
beaucoup voyagé d'avoir parcouru le
monde et la chance de dire
qu'aujourd'hui encore nous sommes le
pays extraordinaire nous avons un
potentiel extraordinaire agricole et si
c'est pour le détruire j'en suis
vraiment triste
merci merci pour ton témoignage qui est
qui et qui est bouleversant et qui nous
met face à nos responsabilités parce
qu'on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons
un nombre d'exploitations très
considérable dans lesquelles les
agriculteurs vont passer la main et
qu'ils vont devoir transmettre à leurs
enfants ou à des repreneurs et donc la
question c'est de savoir si le futur ou
la futur président de la république va
s'engager à s'engager à donner un avenir
à l'agriculture et un avenir crédible un
avenir de confiance pour que nos jeunes
le jeune agriculteur assume la reprise
d'exploitation donc bien évidemment tu
as compris que moi mon objectif c'est
évidemment dette cette présidente qui
donnera confiance à nos agriculteurs moi
je me bats dans une région dont certains
ne savent pas qu'elles et agricoles même
si christian est derrière moi
dans une région agricole pour éviter la
pression foncière la pression
immobilière et le grignotage des espaces
agricoles mais je sais aussi la
désespérance des exploitants des
éleveurs dans des zones beaucoup plus
pauvre que l'île de france et avec des
contraintes qui sont encore plus grandes
alors comment est-ce que faye est
d'abord un scandale premier scandale
auquel il faut qu'on mette fin ce
premier scandale c'est que ça n'est plus
possible que nous ayons dans nos
supermarchés des produits alimentaires
qui viennent de l'étranger et qui ne
respectent pas nos normes
environnementales les normes
environnementales qu'on impose à nos
agriculteurs
des sénateurs cher bruno ont fait un
rapport très intéressant sur ce sujet 10
à 15 % des produits alimentaires dans
les grandes surfaces ne respectent pas
les normes qu'on impose à nos
agriculteurs et évidemment
évidemment ils sont moins chers
et donc dans une période où on a tant de
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh bien les français les
achète donc on mange des produits
étrangers parce que nous n'avons juste
pas le courage au niveau européen d'
imposer des clauses miroir dans les
accords de libre échange c'est à dire de
dire tout le monde respecte les mêmes
lois là l'europe n'est pas on n'a pas
fait l'europe pour ce soit le ventre mou
de la mondialisation un grand marché
pour tous les empires de tout poil on a
fait l'europe pour protéger protéger nos
industries protéger nos agriculteurs et
moi je veux au président de la
république parce que il a finalement
sacrifié la pac on le voit la politique
agricole commune sur le bio c'est quand
même dingue on a demandé à nos
agriculteurs d'enfer on leur a demandé
pour sauver la planète donc un grand
nombre courageusement ils sont allés
alors même qu'on a des normes
environnementales qui sont parmi les
plus protectrices pour le conventionnel
mais ils sont allés sur le bio ils y
sont allés et qu'a fait le gouvernement
il a supprimé les aides au maintien des
exploitations biologiques donc on leur
dit allez-y travaillez plus vous aurez
moins de rendement vous allez sauver la
planète et on leur coupe les aides au
maintien de l'agriculture biologique
selon le bon principe bien connu par
tous ceux qui sont passés comme moi par
bercy
quand ça marche ça coûte quand ça coûte
on supprime bon et dans ma région j'ai
d'ailleurs repris les aides au maintien
de l'agriculture biologique passe comme
on s'y était mis les derniers mais
agriculteurs il était complètement fou
furieux ont leur changer les règles du
jeu mais ils ont fait mieux ils ont fait
mieux il ya eu la loi climat alors moi
je vous le dis tout de suite je suis une
écologiste sincère mais je suis une
écologiste des résultats est pas une
écologiste de la punition dans la loi
climat dans la loi climat qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait il ya eu un amendement
qui a été voté justement sur
l'agriculture biologique est justement
j'en parlais avec les agriculteurs bio
du finistère tu vois pas très loin des
côtes d'armor qu'est-ce qu'ils ont voté
les la république en marche ils ont voté
que les les légumes les légumes sous
serres bio tomates sous serre bio par
exemple
comme on chauffe quand on chauffe les
serres ils ne pourront plus être
commercialisés avant le mois de mai et
ben en espagne les tomates sous serre
elles sont commercialisées dès le mois
de mars qui à votre avis va avoir le
marché des tomates bio donc on peut pas
empiler les normes sur les normes moi je
vous le dis je ferai un comité de la
hache auprès de mon premier ministre ce
comité de la hache il aura comme mission
sabre et toutes les normes inutile et en
matière agricole ce sera tout l'énorme
au dessus de la moyenne européenne
parce qu'on l'a encore on se tire des
balles dans les pieds et c'est pas
possible pour nos agriculteurs
et puis on refera on refera auront
renégociera les accords de libre- de
libre échange agricole mais il ya encore
un autre sujet sur l'agriculture il ya
la question de la ressource en eau la
ressource en eau
les verts les verts nous disent ça va
être l'un des grands sujets
environnementale en heroes de manteau du
prochain mandat
aujourd'hui nous avons des verts qui
sont des bloqueurs ce sont des bloqueurs
et bloque tout ils sont contre tout ce
qui est pour pour tout ce qui est contre
et aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
ressources en eau pour nos agriculteurs
et si nous n'avons pas de ressources en
eau alors ben vous le savez avec le
réchauffement climatique les un certain
nombre d'exploitations vont devoir
cesser leur production donc moi je le
dis il faudra un président de la
république qu'ils aient le courage de
contrer certaines lubie écologistes
parce que la vraie écologie c'est de se
nourrir et se nourrir avec des bons
produits les produits de nos
agriculteurs
alors il ya il ya encore deux choses que
je voudrais dire il ya un chiffre qu'on
ne cite jamais sur le bilan de macron
parce qu emmanuel macron il quand même
sacrément autosatisfaits 1 vous avez vu
quand on a parlé à la télévision l'autre
jour on a fait le premier débat il s'est
précipité à la télé lendemain pour
reprendre toutes nos idées faire un hold
up sur nos idées j'ai un peu sourit j'ai
dit le lundi il y avait la primaire des
républicains c'est quand il ya plusieurs
candidats et que les journalistes posent
des questions impertinentes et puis le
lendemain il y avait la primaire lrm la
primaire elle rmc quand il ya qu un seul
candidat et qui a pas de journalistes
pour poser des questions et qu'on peut
parler 30 minutes pour faire son auto
promotion
bon
mais ce qui est important c'est vraiment
sur l'agriculture de le dire un chiffre
notre balance commerciale
aujourd'hui si on enlève les vins et les
spiritueux
notre balance agricole elle est
déficitaire
nous la france le grand pays qui a
nourri le monde le grenier à blé du
monde nous sommes déficitaires en
matière agricole donc ça nécessite un
grand plan de soutien des dalles
installations de nos jeunes et ça
nécessite qu'on reprenne complètement le
sujet à bras le corps et moi la france
ce sera une france paysanne parce que
dans paysans ya pays x est un très
joliment
bien
on passa à la question de ce côté s'il
vous plaît micro orange et j'ai oublié
de dire parce que pour reprendre la
question d'aurélien pradié que nos
enfants doivent bien manger nos malades
doivent bien manger et donc je ferai un
plein plan pour que dans les marchés
publics d'approvisionnement des cantines
des établissements publics on puisse
s'approvisionner en produits locaux et
en produits bio et qu'on puisse manger
français bien nous saluons l'arrivée du
président du sénat gérard larcher
[Applaudissements]
alors je sais pas si on entend bien
bonsoir madame pécresse même la
présidence je m'appelle maxime renaud je
suis un jeune élu
d'argenteuil de 22 ans ville de 110
mille habitants calme et sereine
contrairement à ce que dit d'autres
personnes et c'est une ville de droite
et j'en suis fier
fièrement heller
fièrement et l'air depuis mes 16 ans
j'ai une question à laquelle j'aurais
aimé avoir une réponse aussi franches
que vous l'êtes vous avez dit durant
votre propos que vous accusez monsieur
macron d'avoir cramer la caisse
assumez-vous votre expression et quelle
est votre vision sur la réduction des
fonctionnaires
je pensais cher maxime que tu allais me
posais une question sur argenteuil et
sur la visite de darmanin mais bon je
vais répondre je vais répondre sur
cramer la caisse mais j'aurai des choses
aussi à dire sur darmanin est sûre et
sur la sécurité et sur la sécurité dans
le val d'oise bon
mais je répondrai à ta question bien
évidemment sur sur la dette la vérité
c'est emmanuel macron aujourd'hui met en
péril les générations futures auxquelles
tu appartiens parce que cette dette de
2800 milliards d'euros eh bien elle nous
affaiblit évidemment au plan
international mais surtout elle va elle
va devoir être remboursés un jour donc
une d'elles la dette d'aujourd'hui c'est
les impôts de demain sauf si nous avons
le courage de réformer le pays alors
vous le savez dans ma région comme
laurent wauquiez d'ailleurs l'a fait
dans la sienne xavier dans la sienne
nous avons pris à bras le corps cette
question du bon usage des deniers
publics pourquoi mais parce qu'on est
champion du monde du paiement des impôts
réveillez-vous champion du monde du
paiement des impôts et qu'on a une dette
de 2800 milliards on ne peut pas
supporter d'avoir des impôts en plus des
impôts en plus sur nos entreprises pour
que on ne crée plus d'emplois en france
et moniales macron nous parle de
réindustrialisation mais la
réindustrialisation 0 aujourd'hui toutes
les entreprises
toutes les entreprises quittent le
territoire ce que je vous ai parlé la
balance commerciale agricole mais que
dire de la balance commerciale tout
court - 85 milliards on est totalement
dépendant des produits étrangers tous
les chèques que fait emmanuel macron
tous les chèques élections qu'il fait
sont des chèques qui servent à acheter
des produits étrangers c'est ça la
vérité aujourd'hui de l'équation macron
alors je les dis je l' ai dit en
souriant on a le prochain slogan de la
campagne présidentielle parce qu'il va
falloir ouvrir les yeux aux français les
français ils touchent des chèques toutes
les semaines le sénat à l'initiative de
bruno et de jean françois husson a fait
le compteur du sénat c est ce que c'est
le compteur du sénat c'est comme pour le
téléthon au téléthon à chaque fois qu'il
ya un chèque il ya un conteur et on
compte l'échec est bien le sénat a fait
le compteur de macron c'est le maquereau
thon
le maquereau thon qui il a démarré en
juillet depuis juillet 42 nouvelles
dépenses
25 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
et
là la dernière décision la plus ubuesque
le rsa jeunes le rsa jeunes alors moi je
le dis ce rsa jeunes je le supprimerait
un jeu si on n'a pas droit de dire rsa
jeunes on doit dire contrat d'engagement
c'est sale mots politiquement correct
voilà bah c'est pas du tout un contrat
d'engagement 15 heures d'accompagnement
contre 500 euros pendant 12 mois ça
s'appelle un rsa jeunes quand nous avons
fait le rsa y avait une contrepartie
d'insertion dans le rsa donc emmanuel
macron le découvre et puis pardon le
dire les 500 euros tout le monde a
compris les 15 heures d'accompagnement
personnes donc le sujet c'est qu'il a
même fait un rsa jeunes vous vous rendez
compte il veut faire des français d
assister des personnes qui vivent des
chèques qu'ils payent avec leurs impôts
voyez dans quel niveau de socialisme on
est arrivé dans notre pays mais moi j'ai
la certitude que les françaises ne
seront pas achetés ils se laisseront pas
acheter parce qu'ils sont plus
intelligents que ça et qu'ils
comprennent que justement cette dette
demain eh bien ce sera une dette qu'on
devra rembourser alors c'est pour ça je
prends aux un programme qui était un
programme de franche rupture de franche
réforme certains diront qu'il est
peut-être un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu libérale un petit peu un petit
peu courageux oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais vous savez
moi j'ai été formé par nicolas sarkozy
il m'a dit ce qu'on dit pas avant on le
fait jamais après et je rappelle que lui
avait mis la baisse du nombre des
fonctionnaires au coeur de son projet
mais non seulement il l'avait mise mais
il l'a fait alors
simplement simplement aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation un peu singulière où
il ya des fonds il ya des domaines de
l'action publique dans lequel il faudra
remettre de l'énergie et des moyens et
puis il ya des domaines dans lesquels il
faudra en supprimer donc moi ce que je
ferais je supprimerai deux cent mille
postes de fonctionnaires des postes il
va y avoir à peu près 600 mille
fonctionnaires qui partiront à la
retraite dans le prochain mandat oh que
c'est un non remplacement de départs à
la retraite sur trois bon je pense que
c'est pas un remède de cheval c'est 0,7
post 7 % de postes en moins par an si on
n'arrive pas à faire ça et donc ces deux
cent mille postes jeu les supprime genre
créé 50 mille cinquante mille dans mes
trois priorités qui sont éduqués soigner
et protéger
ça veut dire que pour la justice on
créera 5000 postes de magistrats 3000
postes de greffiers 2000 postes
d'assistants judiciaire ça veut dire que
dans la santé on créera 25 mille postes
supplémentaires c'est ça mon projet mais
oui je vous le dis on peut supprimer des
doublons administratifs
oui à l'heure du numérique on peut faire
mieux avec votre argent est-ce que vous
avez vu ce qu'a décidé le gouvernement
ils ont décidé de fusionner des agences
parce que vous savez qu'il ya 700
agences agence pareille tactique en
france aujourd'hui 384 comité théodule
alors l'état s'est rendu compte de ça
ils ont décidé de supprimer une agence
ils ont décidé de fusionner hadopi et le
csa le csa s'occupe de l'audiovisuel
hadopi s'occupe de contrôler internet
l'état dit on à faire on va on va les
fusionner bonne décision et ça se
traduit par croire rester assis
dix créations de postes supplémentaires
on est le seul pays où quand on fusionne
deux agences ça se traduit par des
créations de postes donc je vous rassure
moi dans ma région j'ai supprimé 15
structures par un régional
j'ai fait 10 % de réduction d'effectifs
il n'y a pas un habitant de l'île de
france qui se souvient ce que j'ai
supprimé voilà de stockage est ce que
j'ai supprimé
train le costume a donc enfin en tout
cas si je vous dis à ces économies on
peut les faire et on les fera et on les
fera de manière ciblée sur la sueur
administration et puis j'ajoute que je
veux une décentralisation qui soit aussi
puissante que celle de gaston defferre
ou de jean pierre raffarin je veux une
décentralisation massive par blocs de
compétences parce qu'on peut pas avoir
tout le monde qui fait tout et le reste
on peut pas avoir l'emploi qui est
partagée entre l'état et la région avec
un pôle emploi qui m'envoient moins de
demandeurs d'emploi dans les formations
régionales que le site leboncoin
bah oui avec lequel j'ai fait un
partenariat le partenariat avec
leboncoin m'a coûté 0 euros et ils m'ont
envoyé plus de demandeurs d'emploi que
pour l'emploi pourquoi c'est pas de la
faute des agents de pôle emploi c'est
juste qu'ils sont et or
donc ils font ce que l'état leur dit et
alors que évidemment au plus près des
territoires il ya des emplois
disponibles bien on a de temps que pour
une ultime question donc le micro jaune
pour une dernière question rapide oui et
une réponse rapide et un mot de
conclusion peut-être si tu le souhaites
valérie oui merci madame la présidente
ça sera rapide bonjour à tous bonjour
madame pécresse je suis thibault gripoix
je suis élu conseiller municipal
d'opposition vezinhet dans la 5e
circonscription des yvelines et je suis
aussi conseiller national ma question
concerne les familles car j'ai constaté
que peu de candidats de les autres
candidats plutôt ne parle pas très peu
de la famille et on sait qu'en france
nous constatons une baisse depuis dix
ans de la natalité et je voulais savoir
que prévoyez-vous pour les familles
françaises sur merci
alors c'est très important la politique
familiale c'est un marqueur pour nous
c'est un marqueur et nous avons laissé
penser que c'était ringard de parler de
la famille on a laissé françois hollande
emmanuel macron complètement détricoter
la politique familiale et en faire une
politique uniquement sociales ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
les couples des classes moyennes ne
touche plus ou touche beaucoup beaucoup
moins dead pour pouvoir avoir des
enfants est la résultante tu l'as dit
c'est 10% de naissance en moins en dix
ans alors je le dis et je pense qu'il
faut avoir le courage de le dire un pays
qui décline démographiquement déclinera
tout court tout court c'est pas un
hasard si les allemands ou les chinois
lancent aujourd'hui une politique
familiale alors certains écologistes me
diront attention les ressources de la
planète
il faut faire de la régulation des
naissances oui bien sûr au niveau de la
planète faut faire de la régulation des
naissances qu'il faut pas qu'on est con
con qu'on était que la population de la
planète atteignent le ciel mais en
revanche au niveau d'un pays je suis
catégorique au niveau d'un pays il faut
viser le renouvellement des générations
et le renouvellement des générations ça
veut dire remettre l'universalité de la
politique familiale ça veut dire
encourager les classes moyennes à avoir
autant enfants qu'ils le souhaitent et
puis j'ajoute j'ajoute parce que je suis
une femme que c'est cette politique
familiale qui a permis aux femmes de
d'avoir le libre choix entre travailler
ne pas travailler faire des enfants et
ce libre choix j'y suis évidemment très
attachés à leur en doublera les crédits
d'impôt pour la garde d'enfants les
crédits d'impôt pour le travail à
domicile ça aussi c'est très important
parce que ça servira aux familles qui
veulent faire garder leurs enfants mais
ça servira aussi aux parents d'enfants
handicapés et ça servira aussi à nos
aînés qui veulent rester chez eux le
plus tard possible parce que là aussi je
le dis je le dis il y a des aidants
familiaux
on a voulu mais c'est la gauche on a
suivi on a été on a été comment dire
dominés intellectuellement par la gauche
on a voulu rendre collective toutes les
solidarités mais aujourd'hui une place
en ehpad ça coûte combien département et
sa coute combien en reste à charge aux
familles on va pas dépenser à la fin de
sa vie toutes les économies d'une vie
donc le sujet c'est de permettre et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que souhaite
l'immense majorité des français
permettent le maintien à domicile le
plus longtemps possible et ça il faut
rendre solvable les emplois à domicile
pouvoir en avoir avoir des gens qui
viennent vous voir et ce jusqu'à la
toute fin de la vie parce que là aussi
la question des soins palliatifs à
domicile est aussi très importante voilà
parce que la fin de la vie ça doit être
dans la dignité et beaucoup de nos
compatriotes n'ont pas envie de finir
leur vie à l'hôpital je voudrais dire un
tout dernier mot sur les aidants
familiaux parce que c'est un sujet qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur vous
savez moi je souhaite que les aidants
familiaux je sais qu'il ya des projets
de loi en ce sens ils puissent prendre
des congés rémunérés pour s'occuper des
proches que ce soit un enfant qui a des
difficultés que ce soit que ce soit un
parent âgé ou que ce soit un parent
malade
pourquoi un an de congé rémunéré au smic
pourquoi mais parce que parce que les
solidarités collectives d'abord elle
coûte plus cher mais surtout elle il ya
quelque chose d'inestimable qu'elles
n'apportent pas et cette chose
inestimable c'est l'affection alors oui
la famille le lieu de l'affection sera
pour moi un des piliers de la
restauration de la fierté française
bien
à bien
un mot de conclusion ans valérie il te
reste un peu plus d'une minute
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis après dix ans
d'immobilisme et de mauvais choix après
dix ans de déclassement je le dis nous
pouvons reprendre en main notre destin
nous pouvons gagner cette élection
présidentielle nos solutions sont les
bonnes pour le pays vous le savez et ça
se voit et ça s'entend de plus en plus
alors non on n'est pas condamné ni aux
grandes et classement ni au grand
remplacement mais il va falloir un
projet de franche rupture de franche
rupture avec le maquereau nisme un
projet courageux avec des réformes
difficiles et il faudra être prêt le 24
avril il faudra que tous les projets
doit soit sur la table parce que vous le
savez les réformes qu'on réussit c'est
les réformes qu'on fait dans les trois
premiers mois alors je serai prête nous
aurons un projet sur l'immigration
nous aurons un projet sur la sécurité et
la lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
nous aurons un projet sur la
décentralisation et nous aurons un
projet sur la débureaucratisation nous
lancerons la réforme des retraites et la
réforme de l'assurance chômage aussi dès
cet été il faut y aller fort il faut y
aller vite parce que je le sais
d'expérience après il faudra tenir face
à la rue donc il faut être prêt vous
savez on se concentre souvent dans les
élections sur la conquête du pouvoir
mais y'a pas que la conquête il ya aussi
son exercice est aujourd'hui la france
ne peut pas attendre alors avec moi vous
n'aurez pas d'esbrouffe vous n'aurez pas
de fausses promesses mais vous n'aurez
pas non plus de demi mesure je ne suis
pas dans le plaire je suis dans le faire
j'ai envie de dire la vérité et j'ai le
courage et la volonté
de mettre en oeuvre ce projet alors je
suis venu vous le dire
je suis venu vous le dire solennellement
oui le 4 décembre nous serons tous
réunis oui je saurai rassembler oui je
suis prête j'ai un beau projet je suis
prête à présider la france
mais